Lo que vamos a hacer en este video es graficar
algunas rectas
usando las intersecciones con
el eje "x" y el eje "y" de la recta.
Para empezar, una recta está definida por
dos puntos, si encuentras dos puntos,
los graficas, los conectas con una recta y la
extiendes en ambas direcciones,
vas a haber graficado esa línea recta y lo que voy a
hacer en este video, los dos puntos que voy
a elegir son, las intersecciones... intersecciones
de la recta... y hay dos de ellas.
Intersección con "x" e intersección con "y".
Éstas corresponden a los puntos donde la
recta intersecta el eje "x" y el eje "y".
Para asegurarnos que sabemos a qué nos estamos
refiriendo, ésta de aquí en mi papel gráfico, es el eje "x".
Se extiende en ambas direcciones, este es
mi eje "x", mientras que ésta de aquí,
justo a la mitad yendo de arriba hacia abajo,
es mi eje "y".
Éste que tenemos aquí,
es  entonces mi eje "y"....
mmm... creo que no se ve bien ahí abajo,
éste de aquí es el eje "y".
Déjame mostrarte entonces, que quiere decir
intersecciones con "x" y "y".
Hagamos el inciso a.
Inciso a...
déjame hacerlo con otro color...
inciso a... tenemos la ecuación "y" es igual a "2x" más 3.
Veamos qué pasa cuando "x" es igual a 0.
Cuando "x" es igual a 0, la ecuación resulta
"y" igual... "y" igual a 2 por 0 más 3,
2 por 0 es 0, por lo cual "y" es igual a
0 más 3 ó "y" es igual a 3.
Entonces el punto "x" es igual a 0, "y" es
igual a 3, que satisface esta ecuación,
se ubica sobre la recta definida por esta ecuación.
Tenemos así el punto 0, 3.
Vamos a graficarlo.
Este es el punto 0, 3 y observa que este punto
corresponde a "x" igual a 0,
pero se ubica sobre el eje "y", es por eso que le llamamos intersección con "y",
ocurre cuando "x" es igual a 0, pero se llama intersección con "y" porque se ubica sobre el eje "y",
es el punto donde la recta intersecta el eje "y".
Hagamos ahora lo mismo para el eje "x".
Fíjemos "y" igual a 0,
¿y qué tenemos?
0 es igual a "2x" más 3.
Restamos 3 a ambos lados, del lado izquierdo
nos queda -3 es igual a "2x",
dividimos entre 2 ambos lados,
por lo cual resulta -3/2 es igual a "x".
"x" es igual a -3/2 o -1.5.
Tenemos entonces ahora el punto, -3/2, 0,
¿verdad?
Este segundo caso es cuando "y" es igual a
0, sabemos que esta pareja de valores, "x" y "y",
también satisface esta ecuación o
que es un punto que se ubica sobre la recta.
Entonces, -3/2, recuerda que es lo mismo que
-1.5 con "y" igual a 0, aquí lo tenemos.
Y estamos ubicando la intersección con el eje "x"...
intersección con "x"...
ésta es la intersección con "x"...
y si queremos dibujar la línea conectamos
estos dos puntos... conectamos estos puntos
y extendemos la línea en ambas direcciones,
hacia el infinito en ambas direcciones.
Aquí tenemos entonces la gráfica de la recta.
Hagamos otro de estos.
No quiero amontonarme así es que voy a borrar esto.
Borro esto...
y aquí también vamos a borrar esto...
siempre puedes ponerle pausa y volver a ver esto...
déjame borrar esto de aquí...
ups, no debí haber hecho eso.
Bueno, si se llegan a ver los ejes, voy a
volverlos a trazar,
voy a redibujar el eje "x", este de aquí es mi eje "x" y este de aquí es mi eje "y".... ¡ahí lo tenemos!
Hagamos inciso b.
Inciso b se ve interesante.
Entonces el inciso b es 6 por "x" menos 1
es igual a 2 por "y" más 3.
Veamos qué sucede cuando "x" es igual a 0.
Cuando "x" es igual a 0, el lado izquierdo
resulta 6 por 0 menos 1, esto es 6 por -1
y esto nos da -6, es igual a...
déjame distribuir lo que tenemos del lado derecho,
que sería 2 por "y" más 6...
2 por "y" = "2y", 2 por 3 =6.
Ahora, restamos 6 a ambos lados,
¿del lado izquierdo qué nos resulta?
-12 y del lado derecho tenemos "2y",
al restar 6, este 6 es como si lo hubiéramos pasado
del lado izquierdo, al restar 6 de aquí esto
desaparece y al restar 6 de aquí obtenemos -12,
dividiendo ambos lados entre 2
¿qué obtenemos?
Del lado izquierdo -6 y del lado derecho "y".
Entonces, el primer punto que tenemos sobre la línea es el punto cuando "x" es igual a 0 y "y" es igual a -6.
Aquí está el punto 0,6 que corresponde a
la intersección con "y",
esa es la intersección con "y".
Veamos ahora que pasa cuando "y" es igual a 0.
Cuando "y" es igual a 0, vayamos a la ecuación
original y veamos qué sucede...
déjame escribir esto un poquito diferente...
"y" es igual a 0, ¿qué sucede?
Sustituyendo aquí...
voy a distribuir primero esto, 6 por "x" menos
6 va a ser igual, 2 por... cuando "y" es igual
a 0 este termino se cancela y me resulta,
2 por 3 = 6, esto va a ser igual a 6.
Ahora, si restamos 6 a ambos lados o más
bien, sumamos 6 a ambos lados, porque quiero
cancelar este -6, resulta,
"6x" del lado izquierdo va a ser igual a 6
más 6 = 12 y obtenemos "x", dividiendo ambos
lados entre 6, obtenemos "x" es igual a 2.
Así que la otra intersección es "x" igual
a 2, "y" es igual a 0.
Aquí la tenemos, "x" es igual a 2, "y" es
igual a 0 y ésta corresponde a la intersección con "x"...
esa es entonces la intersección con "x".
Y para dibujar la recta conectamos estos puntos...
bueno, no está muy derecho pero ya tienes la idea...
2 puntos definen una recta.
Déjame hacer otro de estos.
Mmm... voy a hacerlo por acá,
en este terreno de acá arriba...
Voy a hacer inciso d.
Inciso c tú lo puedes hacer como práctica.
Inciso d, establece, "x" más "y" es igual a 8.
Este ejemplo es realmente fácil, cuándo
"x" es igual a 0, puedes ver inmediatamente
la ecuación que "y" es igual a 8 y cuando
"y" es igual a 0, casi casi que puedes tapar
esto para obtener "x" más 0 igual a 8,
por lo cual "x" es igual a 8.
Esto fue directo e inmediato.
Tenemos entonces el punto 0, 8... 0, 8, lo
tenemos por aquí... esa es la intersección
con "y" y también tenemos el punto 8, 0,
esa es la intersección con "x",
ya podemos conectar los puntos para que veamos nuestra recta más o menos así.
Y ahora hagamos este problema por acá abajo.
En la tienda de la esquina las fresas
cuestan 3 dólares por libra
y los plátanos cuestan 1 dólar por libra.
Si tengo 10 dólares para gastar, tengo 10
dólares para gastar entre fresas y plátanos,
dibuja una gráfica que muestre las cantidades
de cada una por exactamente 10 dólares.
Bien, voy a dibujar mis ejes, voy a cerciorarme
que estén bien marcados,
recuerda que este es el eje horizontal, de izquierda a derecha y para entretenernos un rato,
en vez de llamarle el eje "x", le voy a llamar a éste, el eje
de las fresas, este es el eje de las fresas...
mejor le voy a poner simplemente con la letra
"f"... la letra "f", aquí lo voy a establecer...
sea "f" igual a número de fresas... número
de fresas y ya sabes por donde va la cosa,
entonces nuestro eje "p" va a ser número
de plátanos...
número de plátanos y ese va a ser nuestro eje vertical...
déjame hacer entonces nuestro eje vertical,
donde vamos a registrar el número de plátanos,
éste va a ser el eje vertical con la "p",
designado por la letra "p" de plátanos...
"p" de plátanos...
Ok, entonces, las fresas cuestan 3 dólares por libra...
ups, aquí tenemos un error porque no vamos
a trabajar con el número de fresas,
más bien es el número de libras,
déjame corregirlo, libras de fresas
y éste de aquí es libras de plátanos... libras de plátanos.
Bien, las fresas cuestan 3 dólares por libra
y los plátanos 1 dólar por libra,
entonces ¿qué tenemos?
3 por el número de fresas o más bien, el
número de libras de fresas, recordemos
más 1 por el número de libras de plátanos y
esto debe ser igual a 10 dólares que tengo para gastar,
entonces 3 por el número de libras de fresas más
el número de libras de plátanos,
va a ser igual a 10, 1 por "b"
es igual a "b" y esto lo puedo escribir como,
"3f" más "b" es igual a 10.
Hagamos la gráfica de esto.
Primero consideremos cuando
no compro fresas, es decir,
cuando el número de libras de fresa es igual a 0.
¿Qué tenemos entonces?
Esta ecuación nos dice que 3 por 0,
más "p" es igual a 10, este término se cancela,
de donde obtenemos que "p" es igual a 10,
así que tenemos el punto donde compro 0 libras
de fresa y 10 libras de plátanos, grafiquémoslo,
si no compro libras de fresa,
obtenemos 10 libras de plátanos, este es el punto.
Veamos el otro caso, donde
compro 0 libras de plátanos.
"p" es igual a 0, sustituyendo en la ecuación
¿qué tenemos?
Tres veces el número de libras de fresas,
más 0 libras de plátanos es igual a 10,
este número se hace 0 y dividiendo ambos
lados entre 3 tenemos, sino compro plátanos
puedo obtener 10/3 de libras de fresas o lo
que es lo mismo, 3 1/3.
Tendremos entonces el punto 3 1/3 libras de
fresas, 0 libras de plátanos...
3 1/3 libras de fresa, 0 libras de plátanos.
Y podemos conectar los puntos para obtener la recta.
La recta completa la voy a dibujar únicamente
en el primer cuadrante, no podemos tener plátanos
negativos, no voy a vender libras de plátanos
y tampoco puedo obtener fresas negativas,
no estamos hablando de vender fresas, solo
puedo comprar estas frutas,
esta es la cantidad que estoy comprando.
Vamos a conectar los puntos y esto es muy
bueno, porque esta línea nos muestra,
todas las combinaciones de fresas y plátanos que
podemos comprar.
Por ejemplo, este punto que tenemos aquí,
no sé si lo tengo muy exacto,
pero si puedo comprar 5 libras de plátanos,
parece que puedo comprar,
ligeramente menos de 2 libras de fresas,
eso es lo que me dice.
En cambio este punto de aquí, si puedo comprar
3 libras de fresas, si puedo comprar exactamente
3 libras de fresas, puedo comprar 1 libra de plátanos,
cada punto aquí representa una combinación de fresas y plátanos que puedo comprar por 10 dólares.